-This is a tradition --
this is six years in the making.
Four years -- this is the fourth
year of this other tradition
First couple of years,
we had one kid --
he could not stay up this late
to be on the show.
Now we got two kids who ar
too young to stay up this late
But now,
for the fourth year in a row
we've dressed up
all of our existing children
whether it's one or two,
in turkey costumes
and our dog Frisbee
as a Pilgrim,
and here is two turkeys
and a Pilgrim.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Happy Thanksgiving!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There it is.
Now -- and we obviously
will send videos.
Face--
You FaceTime with the boys
You sent a video to Ashe.
He's still a little traumatized.
-Yeah, but so am I.
-Yeah.
Explain first where you were
Don't quite explain
what happened in the video
We'll let that be a reveal
-Sure.
Well, my --
my girlfriend's an equestrian,
and she works
at a barn in Malibu,
and because of the fires,
they had evacuated
a couple camels
and brought them to this barn.
-Yeah.
-And I was like,
"Well, I'll take a video
for Ashe of these camels
and send it to him."
-Yeah. And I think
that was good instinct.
I think, you know,
kids like seeing
animals they've never
seen before, like camels.
-Yeah, but I like seeing -
I like seeing camels.
-Yeah, every-- I mean, I think
everybody gets pretty excite
when they see a camel.
-You see a camel,
I hope you're excited.
-Yeah.
-But let's see what Ashe saw
-Hey, Ashe, I come to this barn,
and there's this camel.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
Ohh!
-So, safe to say, he will not...
-Yeah.
-...he will not -- he will not
be engaging with camels much
-Yeah. I mean, well, it was a --
in a lot of ways,
it was a warning.
-It was a warning.
-Yeah.
-And now, every time he sees
a camel in New York City,
he turns and goes the other way.
[ Laughter ]
We've talked a lot
before Ashe was born
about what you guys had --
the big plans
of what you were were going to
be called as grandparents.
-Right.
-You wanted
a Swedish grandmother name
-Yes, Mormor.
-"Mormor" is what you wanted
And you wanted to be called...
-Cisco.
-Yeah, Cisco.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And they -- it didn't take.
Neither of them really took.
-No.
-But, then, you ended up
with grandparent names
that I think are almo--
I mean, equally as unique
as Mormor and Cisco...
-Oh, better.
-Yeah.
-...which is -- early on,
he couldn't say grandparents -
he couldn't say "Grandpa"
or "Grandma,"
and so, instead, he said..
-Panka.
-I was Panka -- Panka Yeri
-Panka Yeri. And...
-I'm Panka Huri.
-Panka Huri.
-Which seems like
some weird Eastern Europea
grandma/grandpa name.
-Right.
-But he refers to you
collectively as The Pankas
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-And it's pretty great,
because...
-It is pretty great.
-Yeah.
-Well, 'cause when
people overhear him saying
like, you know, "Where --
Oh, The Pankas are coming"..
[ Laughter ]
...I think people picture
some real Old World...
[ Laughter ]
-Like the Cossacks or something.
-Yeah, the Cossacks,
like that you're gonna show up
with, like,
pulling a cart behind you.
-"Yeah, Pankas -- they wil
be here later tonight, yes."
[ Laughter ]
"Lady Panka and man Panka.
-"Is good."
-"Is good, yeah, good Pankas."
-"Full moon is good omen
for Pankas."
[ Laughter ]
It's very exciting, though
because it's really fun when
you have to explain to peopl
the origin of it.
-Yeah.
-And, you know,
and, again, like,
I am heartbroken
that you're not Mormor,
and I'm pretty psyched
that you're not Cisco.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, someday,
Josh may have children,
and we have another shot at it
[ Laughter ]
-There is one thing, you know,
having two boys,
and our kids are exactly
the same amount of time apar
as you and I --
2 years and 11 days.
-Yeah.
-Which is crazy.
And I hope that --
you know, obviously, my hope i
that they'll be as good
of friends as we are.
There one thing that
I hope will not be the case,
which is that Axel,
the younger one, like you,
will not sell out
his older brother
the way you did
time and time again
when we were growing up.
[ Audience ohhs ]
Most famously --
-We like --
-Most famously...
-We like rules.
-We like rules in our family
-We love rules.
-I had a -- I had a seriou
orthodonture in my youth,
up to and including a headgear
that I had to wear at night.
-Yeah.
There was no Invisalign.
-No, back in the day.
-Invisalign was not a thing.
-There was heavy gear,
and -- and it was --
I was not getting --
we were not getting
the results we wanted
from my orthodonture.
-No, the orthodontist
was berating me.
-Yeah.
-He said --
implying that I wasn't,
you know...
-Vigilant enough. Yes.
-...exercising enough
parental control.
-How did you take that?
-I didn't take it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-To the point that to --
basically, to encourage me
to wear my headgear,
you offered Josh money...
-Yes.
-...if he could catch me
sleeping without it.
-Yes, because Josh,
when he was little --
he would do anything for money
[ Laughter ]
And so I said that,
if Josh could catch Seth
without his headgear,
Seth would have to pay him
a dollar.
-Yeah.
-And you'd pay.
-It wasn't -- It wasn't --
-Yeah.
It came out of my allowance.
-It wasn't headgear.
-What did we call that?
-Right.
We again -- from the famil
that brought you Pankas,
we -- we called my headgea
my gummy.
-A gummy.
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And, Josh, what was your -
who were you employed by
in these years?
-The Gummy Patrol.
-Yeah.
I was the Gummy Patrol,
working for a --
a shadow organization,
who I can't confirm or den
who it was.
-And, so, can you give a -
just give a normal take
of how
the Gummy Patrol would wor
and how it would go for me
-Well, I would see my target..
-Yep.
-...brushing his teeth.
-Yeah.
-And I would go into his roo
and hide in the closet...
-Yeah.
-...or under the bed...
-Or --
-In a drawer.
-Yeah.
-I was really small.
Under the desk.
And then, as soon as the light
would go out
and it was confirmed
that my target
was supposed to be sleeping,
I would pop out and scream
"Gummy Patrol!"...
[ Laughter ]
...which would be heard by the
in their room.
-Yeah.
-And then it would be, like,
dollar.
[ Laughter ]
-And I do want to stress,
all these years later,
the trauma for me doesn't come
from losing a dollar.
[ Laughter ]
The trauma comes from
you jumping out of my closet
and screaming, "Gummy Patrol!"
And to this day, I can't sleep
without a night-light --
a full-grown man.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you're on television.
Your teeth are pretty straight
I don't know
if they would be without me.
So I feel like...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a very good point.
-You're welcome.
Hillary, Larry, and Josh Meyers,
everybody!